Now, of course, this overview is super subjective and far from complete
and also maybe not always correct but nevertheless.
I think clustering or finding groups of related objects, usually it's a good idea
to try to do a reduction from clique.
Covering a set of objects--that is basically the problem that Alice was looking at
for her Telecommunications Company.
Vertex cover is usually a good idea and there are certain generalizations of vertex cover
called hitting set that can also be a useful tool in proving that problems like these are NP complete.
Optimizing pathways--well, yeah that is shortest tour and also here you should know that
shortest tour has a very closely-related problem and that is the famous traveling salesman problem.
They are not the same but they are very, very close.
Traveling salesman is basically shortest tour, but you cannot visit a vertex more than once,
so it's enforced here, and traveling salesman or the shortest tour problem here,
it is always a good idea to try to use these problems for a reduction when you want
to show that a problem that deals with optimizing pathways under constraints is NP complete.
Now, diversification/independent objects--yeah. If you're a bit test savvy, you would already have guessed.
This is, of course, independent set, and then, finally, something else.
Well, you use our general tool and that is SAT.